[Music]
deaths from the coronavirus have
devastated millions across the world
many couldn't say goodbye to their loved
ones
funerals were restricted making grieving
difficult
but even in normal circumstances one in
ten affected
typically develop prolonged grief
disorder
covert deaths have been even more
traumatic for the bereaved
especially at a time when getting the
support they need
isn't always possible
i'm ben fazeland nice to have you along
dealing with grief is hard enough
but in the middle of a lockdown during
the panic of a pandemic
or surrounded by bulldozers filling mass
graves
that's not easy but it's important to
deal with
there are major health problems to think
about and consequences for life
dw's terry schultz reports on one
belgian family's loss
the world has lost a million lives
one of them meant the world to 10 year
old lorenzo
my grandpa was the best his grandpa luke
picked him up from school each day
and what did you guys do we made
homework
and after that um we
just laid in the couch and just did what
we want to do
mostly i got snacks
but their hometown saint trudean was hit
early
and hard by the coronavirus we had 53
people
who had to enter the hospital and we
only had
beds for 20 people but luke was already
hospitalized
failing fast he said if i don't make it
please take good care of the children
he didn't make it on march 23rd luke
became saint trudean's first corona
death
janine their daughters nella and lane
and lorenzo
didn't even get to say goodbye i had it
really hard
it struck us really hard
yes mayor verlee herren felt it
personally
her husband became critically ill but
survived
it was a terrible time for the families
but also for us as a mayor
but also all the people my policemen you
know the people in the town who were
working
24 hours a day six months later st
trudean has the infection rate under
control with strict measures
father when cunnin says now inhabitants
need to heal
it's important that we share with
with each other what we feel what we
want
our our anxiety but also our
the good things mayor herren decided to
create
a space for that a corner of a city park
is now a memorial
the theme forget me not plenty of those
flowers have been planted by city
landscaper didier summers along with a
tree of life and a plaque
bearing a poem in a hard winter
the flowers will come so yeah even when
it's sad
it will be a little bit beautiful
for the memorial's dedication september
13th
lorenzo was asked to commemorate his
beloved grandfather
he told his mom nelly he was too afraid
because i thought they were gonna laugh
at me
but lorenzo changed his mind and wrote
luke
a letter leave oppa your grandpa
i miss you very much i am mad
about corona mad about what happened
you were the best and always are gonna
be the best
what did you think when you saw yourself
up there that i was brave and that i
was happy that i did it that i could
throw it all out
i was happy
everyone was
even my grandpa no one here
will forget them
[Music]
really powerful stuff there and a great
message about
dealing with grief well martin isma is
an
assistant professor for the department
of psychology at the university of
groningen
in the netherlands how do you deal with
not being able to say goodbye
so this is this is obviously a very very
difficult situation
uh what we see is that a lot of people
are not
able to be physically present uh during
when when the person dies
uh and also that funerals can be quite
limited
in how they are arranged so that not so
many people can be can be there
the example we just saw where there's a
collective ritual to deal with these
losses i think that's great
i think you can also create more private
rituals
with friends or people close to the
deceased
to to say goodbye to the deceased again
when it wasn't when you weren't able to
do that well before
what is it about the pandemic what else
is there that's making it so hard for
people to cope with
losses like these yeah so there's a
there's a couple of things to consider
of course
not being able to say goodbye or not
being able to say goodbye the way you
want to is definitely one of these
factors
but there are also uh uh many additional
stressors that people are now
experiencing
for instance they might uh feels more
difficult to get the social support
feel socially isolated lonely it could
also be
that they're that they're afraid to
become ill themselves
restricted to house or or that they have
a certain other losses that they have to
deal with
such as financial losses or losses of
jobs and likelihood
just in normal look sorry man what were
you going to say
i would say i was going to say that if
you look at covet 19 death specifically
then it's it's it's a different story
still because
then people are also dealing with a
sudden loss um
and and a loss that occurs after
some time in intensive care during which
it's really uncertain
what will happen and i i i and we know
from the
from the scientific literature that
these are definitely risk factors for
for more severe grief reactions
but what will happen because 10 percent
of bereaved individuals
statistically typically develop
prolonged grief disorder
how's covert going to change that yeah
that is indeed the case after
ever not lost due to natural causes
uh we recently conducted the first
quantitative study
into this topic worldwide uh together
with sihalova netherlands
and what we found in a very large survey
of about 1500 people
is that people who experience loss due
to covet 19 actually have stronger acute
grief so
than people who experience natural
losses such as losses due to long-term
illness
and their acute grief levels are more or
less similar
to uh to that experience by people
who have experienced unnatural loss so
then we're talking about
accidents murder or suicide so
so these are very strong uh grief
responses
and we can expect that in the long run
uh the prevalence of prolonged grief
at least within this specific group will
go up and i believe you also have new
findings on people grieving
those who've died from other causes
than um corona during this pandemic
yes um thanks for asking yeah we're
we just had a paper accepted on uh
on this topic uh and and what was really
striking
is that we found that people who
experienced loss
not due to to corona and to the corona
virus
actually also have elevated grief levels
if the loss occurs during the pandemic
but not before it so so that really
shows us that
also within this uh group um there is
a uh people are experiencing more
difficulties uh
initially dealing with loss just in
general is the internet making it
any easier for people to grieve
well what you do see is that more people
are meeting online
and this is not really a substitute but
i think i think that can be a way to
stay in touch
if you cannot meet face to face
but i think you're you might be
referring to internet-based treatments
and in that case i can't say that
internet-based treatments are
indeed available and in the netherlands
there's also groups working on that
so uh there's there's people from
the university of groningen and people
from utah university
developing online cognitive behavioral
treatment for prolonged creatures where
specifically for people who experience
the loss due to cover 19
okay this is a very promising
development martin eisner thank you very
much
for coming on the show today
let's check in now with derek williams
our science correspondent he's been
looking into your questions on the
coronavirus
[Music]
will the developments in the creation of
a vaccine for this coronavirus
helped towards a vaccine against the
coronaviruses that caused the common
cold
wouldn't it be great if something
positive
came out of this pandemic like other
vaccines
for other coronaviruses for example or
or even a universal coronavirus vaccine
of some kind well that isn't impossible
but it's pretty unlikely anytime soon
with all the resources that we're
throwing at a covet 19 vaccine we're
learning more
every day about sars cove too but we
still have a long way to go
in understanding the way that
coronaviruses
in general evolve and the ways that
they're transmitted and we still don't
know
nearly enough about what's called
cross-reactivity which is when
the weapons your immune system produces
to fight
one infectious pathogen also work for
others that have
similar characteristics um there's some
evidence that cross reactivity
in some people might be playing a role
in how
badly they get covet 19 or or
how easily they fight it off but it's
all still
very speculative one promising avenue of
research for example that could help in
the development of future coronavirus
vaccines
involves what's called the the s2 domain
on coronavirus spikes those proteins
that stick out that the viruses use
to latch onto cells that they're trying
to infect
researchers have discovered that these
s2 domains
seem to be pretty well preserved across
the range
of coronaviruses that infect humans
they're quite
similar regardless of which one you look
at
that's a great potential starting point
for working on a broader coronavirus
vaccine
but but it's only that who knows though
maybe one day the work that we're doing
to stop covet 19
might also finally help us stop its
much less deadly cousins
you